hi there today we're looking at weight
standardization by c1 cow who you won
Shan Chi Yu Wei Shen Alan you'll of John
Hopkins University so weight
standardization is a normalization
technique for training neural networks
and it goes basically in conjunction
with another technique called group
normalization so if you haven't group
normalization norm that is ugly if you
haven't seen my video on group
normalization and don't know what it is
I suggest you go watch that first or
read the group norm paper or some blog
post because weight standardization is
usually used together with group norm in
order to work well and that's what this
paper also says even though it's pretty
much independent but here you can see
their main results so they compare batch
norm group norm and weight
standardization used with group norm
then they can as you can see here they
can outperform in the image net top one
accuracy the other two models and the
important part here as you can see is
batch norm is trained with large batch
sizes while group norm and group norm
plus weight Standardization are trained
with one image per GPU so they have a
multi GPU set up and this is just one
image per GPU and these results over
here are on a mask our cm masks are CNN
which I believe is a recurrent model
where the model is large because the
kind of the model is large and therefore
you can only have very small batches per
worker and that means batch norm will
work less again we've discussed why
batch norm is not a good thing when you
have to go to small batch sizes
because basically what people have
discovered is that it is very beneficial
in machine learning to normalize your
data before working with it what do we
mean by it so if you have a bunch of
data points right here and let's say
like this it is it is usually beneficial
to first Center the data like this so
basically calculate its mean and shift
it and then to standardize the axes so
basically you divide it by the standard
deviation in each direction and your
data will look something like this of
many classical methods that will improve
the conditioning numbers of the
requirements to solve it and so on and
even of deep learning methods we just
know that if you standardize your data
like this it works better so people are
basically have come up with these
methods that where they say well if it
helps for the data at the beginning of a
neural network then if after if after a
layer the data is kind of out of whack
that can happen after a layer of neural
network we should maybe first before we
send it to the next layer do the same
thing Center it again and then send it
through and if after the next layer
again it's out of whack we should maybe
Center it and standardize it again
before sending it through the next layer
so it each layer you have these
transformations that Center and
standardize the data and usually for the
longest time this was a batch norm batch
norm does this across the mini batches
of the data since you can't pass the
entire data set now group norm has come
and replaced batch norm because in batch
Arum it's very dependent on the batch
size while group norm isn't the group
norm paper has sort of made it clear
that in Kentucky in competitive batch
sizes in the large batch size regime
group normos sorry batch norm is still
the king batch norm still works better
it's only when you go to very small
batch sizes that group norm takes over
and that's what you can see here so here
okay it's a bit unfair because batch
norm is trained with a larger batch size
but even if group norm were to be
trained with the large batch size it
would still be in the same place because
no it wouldn't it would not sorry that
is that is not the case because the
batches still influence the gradient
stochasticity and so on but still batch
norm is better than group norm as you
can see here but here over here where
you kind of have to go to the small
batch sizes then batch norm is all of a
sudden worse than group norm and the
weight standardization is a technique to
actually make group norm better than
batch norm in any of these so even in
these in the large batch regime okay so
will now explore weight standardization
so in the group norm paper we've looked
at the diagram on the left so basically
in batch norm here is the number of data
points this is your batch this is the
channels of the batch of the individual
images channels and this is the height
and width of the image so this is the
image itself a single channel so a
single channel in the image would be a
column in this thing right here batch
norm normalizes across the data points
in a single channel layer norm which is
a precursor to group norm normalizes
only in a single data point instance but
across all of the channels as you can
see here now that frees its dependence
on the batch size each data point is
traded individually but of course it
sort of convolved all the channels with
each other
it doesn't distinguish them instance
norm tries to fix this instance norm
down here tries to fix this by saying it
was a good idea to own to normalize each
feature individually and takes it to the
extreme basically normalizes a single
image for by each of these single
features but that loses too much
information group norm comes
and says maybe some of the features
naturally depend on each other naturally
exhibit the same responses
therefore we should normalize them in
groups so we take still a single image
but we take groups in this case groups
of three channels together and normalize
across that now this here is all in data
space
this all normalizes the data like we
said up here when we drew this this is
all normalizing the data before passing
it through the next layer now what
actually happens in these layers so what
happens here what happens here in a
convolutional neural network is that the
images get convolved with kernels that's
how that's what a neural network layer
is so if you have an image right here of
our trusty cat I've drawn whiskers in a
while that nose is very high the eyes
must be like up here sorry cat and the
layer inherently has these things called
kernels now I'm just gonna draw one of
these kernels right here it's a 3 by 3
kernel and what you'll do is you'll
slide the kernel across this right
across like this you slide it across
across across across and for each point
you convolve the kernel so you can volve
the values here with the pixels here and
sum them up and that for each position
in the image means that you'll basically
get a new value at each point and that
will be your next layers data point now
in these normalization techniques we
usually normalize the data points so
here you have multiple channels maybe a
red a green and the blue and so on and
did the intermediate layers you have
even more and but you also have multiple
kernels you can see here you have
multiple of these kernels which will
then result in multiple output channels
the old normalization methods batch norm
layer norm group norm they all work in
they all work in this or in this space
in the space of data whereas weight
standardization works on the kernel
space so weight standardization means
you want to normalize the weights of the
neural network not the data and that's
why it can be used in conjunction with
something like group norm or actually
batch norm or layer norm could be used
with any of these but these authors use
it in conjunction with group norm so
what does it do if you have these
kernels the kernels are of our
characterize actually a kernel is
characterized by four numbers so first
of all it's the height and width of the
kernel which in our case was 3 by 3 and
is characterized by two more numbers
which is the C in that in channels and
the out channels so the in channels is
the number of channels that come into
the layer and the out channels are the
number of channels that you want to
transform that into so here you can see
the in channels are listed here and out
channels are listed here and in the
up-down direction which is not labeled
here is the height and width so this
here would be actually a two by two
kernels so each of these slivers here is
a two by two
kernel in the convolutional Network and
then that would be the orange sliver
here and then the sliver behind that
would be the next two by two colonel
weight standardization says hi hey it
might be as we normalize the data it
might be a good idea sorry I was that
was wrong
one column here one of these columns is
a two by two filter and then the column
behind int and the column next to it
a they're all two by two filters right
so you
two by two filters in the output or end
usf two by two filters for each of these
for each of the input output channel
combination you have a two by two filter
so you have an entire matrix of two by
two filters if you can imagine that so
across the out and across the
indirection weight standardization says
how it might be a good idea to see that
the weights for a given output channel
right this is we take one output channel
and we see all the filters that
transform the input into that one output
channel which is going to be this many
times this many times there's many
numbers or this many filters
maybe we should normalize all of these
to be sort of to not get out of whack
because one could imagine that during
training right if we start we initialize
our filters somewhere here you know
maybe one number this is this one number
here we initialize it randomly right we
draw it from random and then maybe as we
train it actually gets very large
because it's actually plausible because
after that we we you know this is our
neural network layer after that we have
this procedure to recenter the data
right so I could make a very large
weight here multiply the data by very
large weight because it gets resented
anyway but of course if my weights get
large I'll basically increase the
variance and the instability and the
gradients might be high and and so on so
these author think it might be a good
idea to normalize these weights so just
as you normalize the data you'd
normalize the weights and this actually
turns out to be fairly easy in the sense
of how you would do it so instead of
transforming X which is the input to a
layer into y using W so this is w this
is your actual parameter using W you
would you won't do this right now so
this this was usually you just do you
just do x times W and that gives you Y
okay this is a convolution operation
right here now you don't do this you do
you have take W and first you subtract
the mean of W this is now for a single
output channel and then you divide by
the standard deviation I'm a standard
deviation of W and that entire thing you
now multiply by X now since these things
here are sorry about that since these
things here or just you know
deterministic operation you can actually
back propagate through it so the forward
path of data now looks as follows you
come you start you say okay my data
comes in
I will take my weights that my layer
weights and I will first Center them
then scale them with its standard
deviation and then I will use that thing
and X in order to obtain my layer output
and then I'll send that to the next
layer now the back prop signal here is
interesting because the back prop signal
comes in from here and splits up into a
it splits up into the back prop signal
basically you have to back prop through
the x times W hat operation we know how
to do that that's just a convolutional
back prop that you back prop through the
convolution operation back to the last
layer now usually when you back drop
through the convolution operation you
get two things you get the derivative
with respect to X and you get the
derivative with respect to the weights W
and you can send both on and you would
update your weights with that gradient
but now what you'll have to do because
this is not your actual parameter of the
network you have to take that particular
signal and you have to basically reverse
the standardization and the centering
before you can
apply the gradient but that's all doable
in the actually modern frameworks will
do it by themselves but it's just that
the the backprop path here in it
introduces two new operation to the
forward and to the back prop path that
you didn't have before
but I can imagine this will actually not
take you won't even notice that this is
happening this is so fast so they the
idea is basically pretty basic
especially since the entire discussion
around normalization has already
happened I enjoy that this paper does go
into the theory a bit more so they
analyze what this weight standardization
what effect it has on the Lipschitz
constant of the loss for example and
they also research what what what
contributes more the centering of the
weights or the standardization so they
kind of run all these ablations where
they figure out okay if we just do group
norm we have one we you know we have
this trajectory here and if we run group
non plus equation 5 which is subtracting
the mean you can see the blue and the
orange that is quite a bit and if we
only do the dividing by the standard
deviation you can see it's pretty close
together but there is a difference if
you do both then again there is a
difference to only doing the centering
so they they say even though you know
probably subtracting the mean gives you
most of the benefit since it is so easy
you should just do both and I honestly
think and here in the in the in the
validation error that makes basically no
difference at all and they do quite a
number of these ablations which I'm not
gonna go into too much and they do also
the sort of Lipschitz constant of the
loss and the Lipschitz constant of the
gradients they basically show that the
loss and the gradients are behaved more
more
well behaved when you use this weight
standardisation technique together with
group norm they also do quite a bit of
experiments where they show that their
method outperforms bathroom and
especially in the small batch size
regime and that is something that I
absolutely believe what happened here
okay
I we actually don't even need to go down
there because um if you want to read the
paper I invite you to read the paper
it's a very good paper I enjoyed reading
it but ultimately they suggest this new
method and also I have seen this one
replicated across the community a number
of times so it seems to be a thing that
I would expect either it fizzes out and
the community decides that it's about
the same as batch norm and therefore not
worth it
or and that's what I believe since we
also go into the direction of larger
models which means smaller batches per
worker and generally batch enorm is a
pain I believe this is just going to be
rather standard in the future so I will
actually incorporate this if I can into
my next projects so that was it for me
if you like this consider subscribing
consider leaving a like on the video
thank you for listening if you have any
comments I will very probably read them
bye bye